have you ever beard into the night sky
in the hope of spotting a shooting star
in this infinite darkness or else a UFO
or another sign that would indicate that
we're not alone in the universe
throughout history man has been keen on
the idea of noticing a sign of any kind
that would show that we're not the only
ones in the space it could be
discovering light after a stretch of
darkness stumbling upon life forms at
the deepest point of the planet or
finding an ally in the far the most
corner of the universe but is it
possible or does absolute nothingness
pervade all around us
[Music]
the first space for most people the
universe is infinite space which the
human brain is incapable of imagining
thanks to the basic knowledge received
at school most of us see the space as a
more or less clear structure of galaxies
planets and constellations but is this
notion quite accurate the universe
conceals a staggering number of
mysteries and it might take centuries to
get to the bottom of even one of them
imagine how much time it would take an
ant to nail the principles of
market-based economy or the amount of
time sufficient for a fish to understand
the structure of a plane
scientists encountered the first riddle
of this kind back in 1978 when they
discovered a phenomenon that did not fit
into the accepted notions about the
universe at the time about 700 million
light years away from the earth a
mysterious phenomenon was discovered by
American scientists in the direction of
the boat s constellation it was dubbed
super void let's see the chronology 1961
the astronomers community's attention is
drawn to free large structural elements
like accumulations of the second order
1978 the first two theses are published
of a subject of boys in a large-scale
structure where voids are mentioned
discovered in front of the Northern
Hemisphere constellation of Berenices
air 1981 the first large void is
discovered in the bow tears
constellation right held on a moment and
now in detail isn't the universe
comprised of a structure of planets and
galaxies equally distributed around the
space
what are these voids then and where do
they come from I bet it's a similar
question the scientists were asking
themselves in 1981 at that time the
universe was perceived as a sort of
canvas filled completely with
constellations and galaxies the image of
unfathomable sky was a straightforward
as a Euclid's axiom stars are grouped in
galaxies and galaxies coalesce thus
forming gravitationally interdependent
accumulations neighboring galaxies are
comparatively close to each other by the
space standards and the voids between
them are insignificant thus rendering
them not worthy of astrophysicists close
attention wrong one here has the
universe ever been simple what with its
great attractors and black Harold's
wormholes and other mysterious
occurrences in 1981 astronomer Robert
Kirchner and his team discovered a
shocking phenomenon that was dubbed the
Botes void or the great nothing
the phenomenon was an enormous spherical
region with a rather small number of
galaxies most of the space was filled
with absolutely nothing a great nothing
which was impossible in the accepted
perception of the universe it made one
assume that for some reason the
formation of galaxies was prevented by
something in this region or else there's
something covered them from the
scientists view with a similar universe
density not less than 10,000 galaxies
would be expected there only eight
however were discovered by the
scientists the odd region was about 700
million light-years away from the earth
would the void 330 million light years
and diameter which is 0.27% of the
diameter of the observable universe the
boat airs void instantly attracted the
attention of scientists from all over
the world and the search for galaxies
within the void became a sword of
competition among astronomers in 1988
three more galaxies were discovered by
scientists then there were 15 in 1989
1993 heralded the number of 27 known
galaxies in 1997 the score stopped at 60
galaxies but this still did not look
enough during the 40 years of its
existence the mysterious void has kept
attracting astrophysicists the first
riddle that puzzled the scientists lay
in the fact that galaxies never went
into the void but bounced off does it
ring a bell maybe some sort of a white
hole is concealed there in the infinite
darkness
scientists are still uncertain as to the
origin of the boat as void in computer
models little voids are formed when
galaxies merge and leave their place but
it doesn't account for the boat as void
galaxies would not have enough time to
vacate space for the voids to form
taking into account the age of the
universe and the speed with which it
expands the size of the void would grow
tens of millions of light years but not
hundreds the boat as void is too great
to fit these calculations that is why a
new theory was conceived according to
some scientists large voids are formed
by smaller ones just like a big soap
bubble is formed by smaller bubbles the
way of the galaxies are arranged in the
boat as void could be indicative of just
this there in a row and this could be
the remains of two voids that once
coalesced there are other numerous
theories as well perhaps you also have a
hypothesis as to what could be concealed
and avoid please leave your comment
even though studying this phenomenon is
a complicated task the boat s void is
just the first stage of studying voids
in the space scientists have by now lost
count as to how many voids there really
are in the space today voids account for
a large portion of the universe and
their main feature is their mystery it
is not even clear how they came about
they are conventionally believed to form
when parts of matter blend and vacate
space in theory voids were small in the
early universe and later on they
expanded but so far no general rules of
void distribution have been formulated
scientists estimate them to occupy half
of the universe or even most of it up to
90%
mikail aniseh mauve wrote the void is a
desert an ideal vacuum where particles
of matter travel through millions of
light years
without collision or change the void is
a repository of motionless time for them
there the time stands still
indeed just imagine hundreds of light
years of absolute nothingness darkness
and cold where time is virtually
non-existent from the technical point of
view this void is not supposed to exist
as contemporary theories admit of only
much smaller unfilled spaces the
dimensions of this void monster alone
need fresh theories among which those of
the wackiest variety like alien
interference or something worse science
does not stand still but the real world
keeps feeding us with new riddles
paradoxes and inconsistencies we just
have to accept the rules of the game to
keep playing and try yet another time to
understand how it all works that's all
dear friends like this video if you were
at least mildly interested subscribe to
our channel so that you don't miss new
videos about mysterious phenomena in the
space and leave comments about this
video what was exciting or maybe made
you feel terrified like it did me thanks
for watching keep in touch
[Music]
you